كل الخيارات متاحه اذا ليكون السؤال ما هي
الخيارات التي تمتلكها اسرائيل ان وصلت
ايران لنسبه التخصيب اللازمه لانتاج قنبله
نوويه الخيار الابرز والمطروح منذ فتره هو
تنفيذ هجوم على المنشات النوويه الايرانيه
وخلال الاسبوع الماضي فقط بحسب الاعلام
الاسرائيلي اجرى رئيس الحكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو خمسه نقاشات سريه بحثت هذه الخطه
ورفع الجهوديه جهوزيه الجيش لتنفيذها
نتنياهو يرى ان التهديد النووي الايراني
لن يتراجع الا بعمل عسكري العقوبات
الاقتصاديه ليست كافيه
اذا هناك خطه للهجوم لكن هل تل ابيب جاهزه
للتنفيذ مصادر عسكريه اسرائيليه قبل شهر
واحد من الان اكدت ان خطه الهجوم على
منشات ايران النوويه ليست جاهزه تماما وان
التحضير لامريكا هذا سيستغرق عامين على
الاقل لكن بالفعل تحضر اسرائيل نفسها
لهجوم كهذا منذ فتره ففي سبتمبر عام 2021
جزء كبير من زياده الميزانيه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه
من اجل شم هجوم على ايراني قبل ايام
استثنت تل ابيب ميزانيه الدفاع من مناقشات
الموازنه زادت مخصصات برنامج ضرب ايران
بنحو مليارين وثمانمائه مليون دولار في
مايو من العام الماضي اجرى سلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي مناورات واسعه النطاق والهدف
كان واضحا محاكاه هجوم على المواقع
النوويه الايرانيه ميزانيه وخطه وتدريبات
لكن ثمه امرا قد يعرقل خططنا
الداخل الاسرائيلي المتفجر
بعيدا عن كلام السياسيين الاسرائيليين
لاهداف داخليه فان دوائر امنيه
واستراتيجيه اسرائيليه تحذر من تبعات
مابات يوصف بالانقلاب على نظام القضاء في
اسرائيل لجهه التاثير على ملف الامن
تحديدا اولا من خلال ان ذلك قد يفهم ضعفا
من قبل قوى خارجيه مثل حزب الله والفصائل
الفلسطينيه ما قد يغريها للعمل العسكري
وثانيا ضرب معنويات قوات الاحتياط التي
تشكل ثلاثه ارباع الجيش الاسرائيلي في
القتال في الحرب المقبله وثالثا والاهم
التاثير على المواجهه مع ايران لجهه تضرر
العلاقه مع واشنطن فمثلا مجلس الامن لم
يناقش تخصيب ايران لليورانيوم لاكثر من
80% لكنه ادان سياسه الاستيطان
الاسرائيليه